i'm about to uber fact check these uber
facts are you a motion graphics designer
that has
really top-notch editing skills there's
a link down below for you to apply
do it do it let's just get started after
kissing someone passionately their dna
can linger in your mouth
for more than an hour i don't know why i
threw that passionately thing in there
but this
is true not only are you sharing the
bacteria
fungi viruses all of the microbiota that
exists inside your mouth you're also
sharing some of your dna it's also
called saliva swapping
bonding with dogs causes your brain to
release dopamine and oxytocin in the
same way as loving a child
there you're like my child it's also the
same thing that's released when you're
cuddling with someone oxytocin is also
known as the cuddle hormone but you also
let off uh something known as beta
endorphin which also is a feel-good
positively attributed neurotransmitter
that
uh your body just makes you feel love
the human mouth is
dirtier than a toilet seat ah
this i mean it depends on your
definition of dirty because if you're
doing strictly bacteria
it is true if you ever actually hit
someone in the face
with a punch and their tooth goes into
your knuckle that could be a
fight bite so that when the bacteria
gets into the joint or near the joint
when you reposition your hand like that
it can no longer escape gets trapped
puts you at risk for osteomyelitis a
bone infection septic arthritis a joint
infection
and those are quite serious so we give
antibiotics
really quickly for fight bites a human
sneeze can travel about a hundred miles
per
hour yeah this is true we've seen on
slow motion camera
where like the sneeze droplets the micro
droplets the ones that probably aren't
carrying viral material
are shooting as far as like 27 feet away
the reason we say stay six feet away for
like the
influenza and covet 19 is because we've
seen that the majority of the heavy
droplets that carry the virus
actually fall at that six feet rate but
it doesn't make you 100 protected
by any means why did that lady just
sneeze on her cat
the largest bone in the human body the
femur can support 30 times the weight of
a person's body this is in fact true
strongest bone in the body oh hey bear
also the reality is to fracture the
femur
it needs to be a high speed car accident
a very high fall you're not gonna just
fracture your femur
as a young healthy adult by walking on
the street and taking a slip
if human dna were uncoiled it would
stretch 10 billion miles
10 billion million miles that's
equivalent
going to pluto and back i gotta fact
check that because that is
excessive this fact
is actually not true each cell in your
body has dna if we uncoiled it it would
go about six feet and then if you add up
all the cells in our body
that adds up to 67 billion miles
which is a hundred fifty thousand round
trips from here to the moon i don't know
about you but i've never taken a round
trip to the moon if i would i wouldn't
do it 150
000 times the highest blood alcohol
concentration
ever recorded was 0.91 more than twice
the usual lethal level and 11 times more
than a legally intoxicated person
it is potentially 11 times more than a
legally intoxicated person but
let's see what the highest recorded on
record is i'm sure i can find that out
all right this one's false there are
much higher reported levels across the
globe on this the important fact here is
actually
anything above a 0.5 blood alcohol
content is respiratory failure death
coma etc when doctors say they need
something stat
it is a shortened version of the latin
word statum meaning immediately
instantly immediately yes this is true
and that's why
we say chest compressions chest
compressions chest compression stat
because they should be done
immediately when someone's unconscious
without a pulse the pentagon spends an
estimated
41 million 600 000 a year on viagra uh
we fact check this
it is absolutely true and if you combine
it with drugs like cialis levitro which
have the same mechanism of action
that totals 294 million dollars the
reality is sometimes we prescribe these
medications for pulmonary hypertension
in order to lower the pressure in the
lungs some of the other ones are also
used for prostate issues
so don't judge and think that it's all
about fun
and sometimes it's about procreation if
a male pees on a pregnancy test and the
results
are positive it could be indicative of
cancer i like that they put the word it
could be
because there are certain tumors
specifically testicular tumors
that produce this hormone beta hcg which
is what we test
for when we give you one of these
over-the-counter pregnancy tests so
while it's not something i would use as
a screening method for cancer if it does
show up positive that's a good reason to
go see your doctor
british researchers have found that one
smile
can generate the same level of brain
stimulation as up to 2 000 bars of
chocolate
that is a lot of chocolate fact check
time it is true
and it can give you the same
neurological boost as receiving 25 000
so smile away flow is the mental state
your brain enters when you're completely
involved in an activity that brings you
so much joy you lose the sense of space
and time
truth when you go let's say rock
climbing you're playing the piano for
fun there is no financial benefit sexual
benefit
work benefit and yet we put so much
effort into doing this burning calories
it doesn't help our survival one bit
yet we do it why flow that's why when
you set little goals for yourself
throughout the day
that bring you joy and they're
attainable goals and we create
friendships along the way
this is the secret to fulfillment i
don't want to say happiness i'm going to
say fulfillment
humans have the same number of hairs as
chimpanzees
but our hair is useless and often
invisible i mean if you're talking about
peach fuzz
maybe but the reality is through
evolution we actually
end up losing the majority of this hair
for me what's interesting is the hair
that has remained and the reasons why it
has remained for example like think
about the eyebrows
why do we have eyebrows it's really as a
way to serve
as a non-verbal communication
representing threat or hostility
exercise
reorganizes the brain so it is more
resistant to stress
i don't know if reorganizes the exact
term but yes
this does happen in fact the brain uh
has a factor in it called brain derived
neurotrophic factor
which actually nourishes and matures new
nerve cells to form and as a result you
become
more cognitively capable more likely to
be comfortable dealing with stress
even oxidative stress to some degree
some level of activity
is almost always beneficial to the human
mind mind and body
the average person falls asleep in 10 to
20 minutes
i know for the people who are insomniacs
out there they're going to get
frustrated by this
this is somewhat true my general rule is
if you're rolling around in bed for more
than
20 minutes and you can't fall asleep you
probably should get up and try and do
something else that's calming in order
to help you get sleepy again and then
come back into bed and try again because
once you lay there for 20 minutes
you start developing anxiety and
frustration with being in the bed not
falling asleep it's actually
conditioning you to be more anxious the
next time you go to bed as opposed to
leaving the bed
being anxious somewhere else calming
yourself down and then going into bed
when you're already tired
that's the optimal approach for caffeine
addicts coffee doesn't
actually increase alertness above
baseline levels it just reverses the
fatiguing effects of acute
caffeine withdrawal there was a study
done on this that actually did confirm
it
however it's an imperfect study i think
that yes if you need that temporary
boost especially early in the morning
it's totally fine to have a cup of joe
however
do not have it after lunch because
caffeine takes several
hours more than six hours to clear out
of your body
so if you're taking it at four or five
o'clock when you're going to bed you're
gonna still have some caffeine in your
system
making it difficult for you to fall
asleep or if you're one of these addicts
that says oh i can drink caffeine and
fall asleep like a baby
yeah you can but guess what you're not
gonna go through all the stages of sleep
well
you're going to wake up feeling
unrefreshed boom it's possible to die
from a broken heart
this condition is called stress
cardiomyopathy actually it's called
takutsobuz
no takutsobo cardiomyopathy usually
this causes a non-ischemic heart attack
meaning it's not because of a blocked
blood vessel and your heart ends up
suffering from a lack of oxygen
ninety percent of the reported cases are
in women ages
58 to 75. a sunburn is the result of
your skin cells killing themselves to
protect you from their damaged dna which
can cause cancer yeah this is somewhat
true because
they're experiencing what's known as a
type 1 program cell death when you have
radiation injury your body understands
that there could be genetic mutations
there so it goes through this programmed
cell death
creating an inflammatory response it's
very painful
there's peeling the skin cells actually
flake off
this is a protective mechanism of your
body meditation is such a powerful
technique that after only eight
weeks the brain structure changes i
don't know where they got this eight
weeks from couldn't find that anywhere
in the research but the reality is
meditation does change your brain's
electrical activity the way we should
think of mindfulness and meditation
is just like any other exercise that's
why the more you do it the better you
get at it our brains tend to be
anxious beings that constantly are going
all over the place
and when you try and control it for a
short period of time of mindfulness that
takes effort it's hard that's why you
should do it for a short period of time
and then work your way up to longer
periods of time and when you do that
your brain structure
is somewhat changing so yeah meditation
all the way listening to music while
exercising can measurably improve your
physical performance
yes not only can listening music affect
your physical performance it could also
affect your brain waves its
changes in music and also silence can
have the same effect music that has like
a crescendo where like it's like
a drop or a climax in it will affect the
way your brain is reacting it's
really really cool sweat is actually
odorless the smell is caused by bacteria
that live on the skin
i want to say true cause like when
people smell bo
they're really smelling bacteria farts
so it's true on that end however
however however there are
pheromones that sometimes have their own
unique scent
that is released when you stress sweat
and by the way when you smell something
that's just a chemical receptor in your
nose like it's not even a scent receptor
just census chemicals how cool is that
spongebob also spreads misinformation
click here to check that out and as
always stay happy
and healthy uber fact or not
[Music]
you